はじめまして碓氷第一と申します
私はグローバル展示メーカープログラム g 1000フィートいう団体の代表を務め
ています
この団体は版られシア
宿店酒田市の広立つをといった国内外拠点でのフィールドワークプログラムを企画運営
している団体です
私はこの団体を大学3年生の時に大学の友人4伊藤
立ち上げましてチェーンエイサーの排出という一緒のはかりで活動を行っています
実は私1年の違法この会場にたんですね
といいますのも共演のて零細 see you のラストもっと進んでも三好大輔と
いうものがですね
d 先生の初代代表でもございまして彼らが登壇するというのを聞いて久しぶりに会い
に行こうということで前に来ましたということでお茶にこの三好ジョイス気の遠く
去年会場で聞いたりとか youtube で見たもだるいいくとってどれくらいい
ますか
自分に思えますねありがとうございますそれ本当に私彼の話をこの開度で客席で
13傘として聴いてまして外飼い気になって政治の上でしゃべることになるので非常に
大変驚いて光栄です
じゃあな一応その照れくさい主流の話もらったところにこれをや今後は近いだろう見た
かな一応
おい何ですね照れくさい see you の動かもらったよ
テープしているいました
またこの枚が店出てくるとみたいな感じの反応がか言って
ティアの私が想定シューズ最も悪い林が来てですね
あれあのな小長井屋根グラビアてる行ってみたいな
もう会が有名
映画が話をされてしまってですね
私そんなに経緯のオファーを受けるものが役者たちに足りない
さの一つですねまぁそんなわけでうちの母親が強硬に来てますっていうこともなく
あのなんかねえ
ぎゅう宴し結局2入ったからとか言ってですね
幕張でやってるフィギュアスケートのふぁんたじんをは言った
田中2位出かけていきましたことですね
ほんと店頭の本部の方この冬季聞いたりしてぜひ日本の子お母さん世代というか
主婦層にですねリーチブランディング頑張っていただいてですね
本当に小屋不孝ものの30アラサーの男の仙台自分の親孝行のチャンス逃したのでぜひ
頑張っていただきたい
では早速なんですけれどもなぜ夢以外の持ち物については語られないのかという
東方していきたいとおもいます
まず初めにお聞きしたいんですけれどもその中で方
なかなか素直になれないなぁとかもっと素直になりたいなぁなんていう
思うことを持ったり悩んだり言ってる人って
どれぐらいいらっしゃいますか
でも続々上がってきませ周りの人があげたらあげるぐらいの
ありがとうございますいいかゲイ素直じゃないですね
ですね今日は本当にその素直
d なれないっていう部分カラースタートしたお話でしてちょっと変わったパイプなん
ですけどこんな話から始めてみたいと思います
私たちは小さい頃からですね先生とか親から夢持つことってすごくいいことだよ
あのぜひぜひ大きい夢を持ちましょうなんていうことを言われて大きくなってきたと
思います
わたしそれはすごくそうだなぁと思うんですけれども
じゃあ方
疑問が一つあるんですねこういう持つことが素晴らしい触れますそうなんだと思うん
ですが
夢を動かなるといけないのか
そしてはたまた方夢を持たないと幸せになれないよ
っていうのを果たして方向なんだろうか
っていうことを考えたんですねそれは私にとってすごく重要な命題でなぜならこっち
どうしてもじーっとや夢を持ってるとか言っていう単語がどうも自分に似合わないなっ
て思っていたんですね
序盤にもあの私基本変な人だよってこと序盤にお答えしておきたいので
calcio 登場人物と位置関係で取扱説明書みたいな話
いうと
他人がいて自分があるとこれ私の親しい友人複数の人から言われたのが好
偽物の薄いライチが入ってこうなんか宝具の水だいた後頭部の斜め上に実態が浮遊して
いるの
ラジっ子を楽しむかのように操縦しているみたいなこと言われですね
でまぁそれいいで妙だなあと思うのが加工
私の今何何ですって降格 ip って自分を上から見ていてその絵が糖度こそばゆくて
ですね
盗んだかうん無理になっちゃったんですね
になっちゃったというのはチークい頃は割とちゃんと言っていたんですが大人になるに
つれて
何か言えなくなっちゃったなと思いますでこのへんな写真よって来ない出てきました
けれども
小さい頃は私の夢は何ないですと言ってた
これ幼稚園から大学に至る薄いライトの成長の軌跡です
まず最小がですねあのこれあの皆さんご存知行為オスポンプなんですけどあの子の
ポンプがですねおち幼稚園の頃にすごく大まあになれるんですが科学の中で梱包
なんか普通にした人は天才なにいないな
発言すばらしいですだからウォッチ幼稚園の頃によくわかんないんだけど
壮大発明家皆で言ったらしいですね
でただその4先生の私薄い少年は気が変わるのが早いですね
幼稚園の側縁群衆にはサッカー政治を通らがかかりません
新しいここ後あろうに小学生になった薄い方年はバスケットボール部に入ったんですね
場合の影響なんですけどそう思ってくるその頃からでしょ
夢って聞かれたらちゃんと私は答えなきゃと思って答えないんですけどこれゆえこう
ファイルになるのかなーみたいなことを
今後い初めてそうですかめんどくさい少年を超えちゃうまいります
になった頃にはテレビドラマねーけど法律に興味を持ってまして
将来だった裁判官になるん
いいな私は高校
を卒業して早稲田大学に入っ
政治経済学部の経済学校そう
なぜ工学部じゃないよっていうのはもう私が一番いいもんなんですけど
ない方大学中にがあ
2研究会というバナー一三共するでスタッフに
範囲ましてスポーツ実況活動責任者などを務めます
そこアナウンスは楽しくて
でそのためですね
非常にいうって何だろうってなってしっかりがあったんですけれども
同給付課課の箒にもたくさん after 志望の方のおりまして
ああああん刹那面白いなっていうことでアナウンスたーーー
治験受け始めました
ブービー以下はれているんですけど
here 24ひぁっ7人前くらい
私これ以上私自身の命のために6とグー映像から等兵写真くださいと言われて没に
facebook のプロフィールガードしちゃってなおちゃんだ
そのうえで応募写真とかさっきのあの登場の時の3月だけでそうかチョイスしたどう
いうものなのでこの写真めっちゃイケてるところで使ってくださいとか日本もいけない
けどこの場で確認を出していただきます
あちらのこれらの左が初めて番ぐらいでし写真大学3年生で右が昨年2月いった写真
です
私この before after ダッシャー庫下の成熟の iphone に入れ
て着最新の顔を探してますので
なんか詐欺が詐欺だっていう批判は当たらないのでいます
話を元に戻しますと就職活動っていうタイミングはば戦力すごく被って就職活動って1
日杯飲んで複数回交
あなたの夢は何ですかとかあなたの本当にやりたいこやりたいことなんて本当にだっ
つっにやりたいことは何ですかっていう
を食べたで聞かれていて
なんかおお
ランとか言えないといけないっていうところ好きじゃなくて
そんなこんなでそこから完全に夢というテーマに対する回表拒否が始まりまして
そんな方まで州昇格でもちょっと中田んぼの大変有ストップしてしまいました
私ほどそんなに一つのワードをこれらせる人遠くないと思うんですけれどもこう就職
活動真っ盛りの人とまぁ結構コミュニケー登ってみるともっというものなんだから
夢とかそういった本当にやりたいことってみたりする
なんか軽い暴力性というかいまかとか固まったん
まあここに行くのはなんかを夢を多くなきゃ夢を見つけになきゃっていう感覚
ん
いう方から催行されたんやっていう人は少なからがいるんだなと思って
ですね私は考えましたホットれ早急に日本海なだめながら考えたんですけれどもこう
いう以外の持ちも撮ってないのかな
ゆうゆう遅ずと豊かに生きられるのはわかったから
国会議員なぜかこれたら一幸せに充実して過ごせるようなっていうものはないかなって
考えてみにつでちょっと並列に仮説を立ててみました
夢思う
持っ
自衛官を持っ
いうところでして
あの言えばもちろんわかると思うんですけど私ですね周りにすごくお宅も友人が大量に
行けですね
彼らはでまぁある人はほうきで洋服作って
春日と本気でしていう本をかけて言って
あのアイドルに情熱を注ぐまでです市役所職員の人と話をしたと思うんですね
いやオタク業をやるにはもう行為の最高やぞ
安定した収入と金曜夜から後日祝の圧倒的なスケジュールの見通しか見たい
日本語10年20年もらえるんだったらもう公の毛牧野られまへんみたいなこと言って
てめっちゃ楽しそうなんですよね
値段はオタクだけじゃなくても
7スノーボードとか車とすごいいけない人はスキルと思うけど
かでなって
その自分の国に a 4を買っても動かって話を覚えようとしないんだよね
自分の好きなことで好きなことを仕事にしていこうとかっていう話でもしないし
それをこうしてめちゃくちゃねか夢を掲げてるって言うことでもない
いうこと
主任と一緒で新刊を釣っても凄く充実につながってるなぁと思う
ただオタクの次にマザーフェルトの話でも凄い挟射なんですけれども
マザーテレサさん来てすごいことを成し遂げているけどうれしい大きな方法を
成し遂げるのか夢を実現したということであまり口にじゃなくて
印象的なストーリーがあるんですね
まず人がまだてさぁ皆さんあなたはこんなに大きなことを成し遂げられたんですか
ポイントして
私はその大きなことはできませんししてません
私はメモ前のチーズのことに大きな色をこいで
候補している方これだけですよここ
そこに競泳史になると風邪講義青でっていうのはそこに現れていなくて
すごく
自分の使命乗って競馬し
一つ一つが充実した人制ゆな方もバラしてるんだなーって思う
これ解放ですよ夢を持たないし青てられないっていうことに関しては一
そこからなんか逃れるために一筋の光が見えた気がしたんですね
ここで新たな疑問が生まれるんですよ
ゆる以外の持ち物が具体的に見えたところでー
例えばこう
こういう絵とは言えないンゴ兵部ないしかないなーって
おかあ
あとはを
指示のはなんで使って言われて
雨即答できない首位とは言えないのがちょっと楽しい
好きな国はやってます暗い
もう暇つぶししかないなぁ
頭とこうなんかこう世の中にいいな子をしてみたときに
これって本当に自分の使命感でやってるかななんかいい人と思われたくてやってるか
なんかこういい一振りしてるっていうのを自分で自分に対して思ってしまったか
っていうものがあったときに果たしてちゃ
具体的に言えばもあるよって話が出た時に
本当に充実してあるのかな
主なしまったんですね
私の大学卒業紆余曲折を経て国際協力乗っているので仕事をしているんですな
いい
左の
バングラデシュのダッカ首都ダッカの写真なんですが私4アジアの工場ほぼ新興国に
ほっ繰り返し繰り返し行っている経験をこうして思うことは
日本は
夢も希望も本当に何も持てないって言う
話であるとかあまりのよいうのがまず下によって何の後ラックを楽しむ機会のよりもな
いっていう人はもちろんいるんですけれども
明日後で一つとしてそこまで多くはない
どちらかといえば先ほど者23つのだったらその身につに対してアクセスできそうで
できていないしえいないっていうのも中途半端感よって自分をなかなか肯定できてい
ないという人の方から御倍なんじゃないかと思います
私はこれに対して行ね誰にもこうなんか転用可能な絶対的な背景咲くなんてものは
を伝えいないんですけれども
私1ポイントしてこんなことを経験して福楽に生きてますしてような
総合話をしてみたいと思います
彼はですね
夢
ciel
その3つをですね
陰で全部のために聞いてに集約して
客様の層に生前様っ
私はそんな人物とフォースしたことによって
ぷと楽に生きるヒントを得ます
これは雑誌フォードしてた訳
30人のアジアの若手社会起業家というもがでも選ばれた
美馬回帰という事務
これはですねこの辺を語ります
映像教員の力を使って世界でも教育格差をなくすんだ
そして者から本舗にない弾けなものがあるんです
このまま高層国の文化がし人が好き空気が好き
でこれもっともっと映像教育したり自分を教えとして受けていた
思っ0 e 9すごい大事なんですね
なので開発教育と入れているどれ取り組みながら本もこれは仕事なのかどうなのか
音をない
だから闇ばっかりに開く人ってカイエンカイエンって言うんですけれども
その名前すごく大変誇りに思っていて
開発教育のフィールドでしっかりテープを出すことそして世界中の若者目反応性を開く
ことに対してもも福祉名鑑
自分の人生をかけてやるんだっていう思いを食べたり口にしています
私はですね下に乗って彼のサポートをすることになりました
お手伝いをしています
そして彼
から気づいたことがいい音ですね3つする方法であっている人っていうの渡部さんの人
を惹き付けて
大きな力が大きな売れよう生み出し
もう一つ気づきました
彼はのようなですね密着度工房の一台買いにしてスキルエフェクトは完璧じゃないん
ですよ
あの公と僕を張っているとですね数字とか制度細かい話とかですねその辺明らかに御刀
間私くんです
隠すことなくなってくるんですね
なのでそういう人を見てきたときに
a 棟
誘われたんですね助けてくると思う
私大カレー大学1年市場くね上の先輩でして
共通の友人を踏むすごく数年愛お互い人となりは知っている関係者
えっとを落としの5型にとあるイベントで一緒に参加して
帰り道0
こういうの銀ポイントで事務局長やってくれない発表マンをいただきました
もともと学生二月として
スタート者さん elk ショップで栄養教諭のプロジェクトなんですが
介護でで法人化してしっかりプロフェッショナル集団をつくっていくという箇所を切り
たい
その想い
答えを言うここで npo 法電化してフル第二版第2志望をして昨年から私は
お仕事が始まりました
僕も自己紹介へ直行説明が入っていなかった部分なんですけれども
私ねその就職活動を応援た後
大風老女しました大学を4年で卒業生で5年生にことにしています
そして5年生の秋冬いら辺でもで何一つ
シーンは固まらないんですねえ
結局そこでものファーストキャリアはサークルの先輩に誘われたというただそれだけの
いいんで
終わればいいとこの時代でさんとか5人ぐらいの小さな学習力で働き始めました
この腕の glp とで団体は学生の時に立ち上げて
合格主義でも仕事を始めてから彼等を続けていたので皆さんからをパンいただいた
タイミングでですね
瀬織恵北の順ように言います
その結果等 gc mt に代表そして
elk 所の事務局長という
二眼タイプもバングラデシュに深く関わりを持っ
二つの団体の運営に携わるもいるうまりこ
フレアキャリアに光沢あるしましたん
ここにきてなんだけ悩んでないの考えてだった人間の真方の結成だったら増加にあり
ますですね
本当にこの場所で何も考えたり頑張ってくれたんですねっ
なんかこう事務局長や展をやっちゃうくらいの感じで動いて a 今じゃ自民党にとっ
て何してるの
いう
えっなんでも屋です裏方何でも屋7 ja 組織分強化につながるものは何でもやれる
仕事です
後方オファー流れる会計時に品
目に見えないところもすべて中国をここにまとめていて
昨年末パナソニックさんが nem 組織基盤強化に対する助成する事業を伝えたくさ
れまして
本当に目に見えないところも仕事を裏デー
国際協力の段階なんですけど日本
メイン表面おいて仕事をしています
でなんでもやっていたんですけれども基本的にですね
共通項があります
トップが実現したいものにつながる仕事です
なのでわたしのすする仕事を得曲の片方がワード野郎が
裏でコソコソと調整しようはそれをしついて
トップの実現したいないというものにつながっているかどうかそこだけを判断して
しごくをしています
彼も経験をこうしてですねすごく大事なことを学べました
それはまず言えっていうのは自分ひとりで全部動かなくていいということを学びました
それは彼私がの目の前にいた excel パパ方が等星翔がその小さな小さな貢献は
彼の10よって海の向こうの数百数千の子どもたちに届けてもらえるという
明確な達成感を得られた感じです
そしても多いなぁ
そういったかで目の前のスーパースターが自分の小さな貢献を昇華させてくれた時に
十分に嬉しいよね
なので身近な人への小さな貢献はその音の前のスーパースターを介して夢一途がお
すそ分けされてくるように出来ていいんだということがストーンをハナに行きました
この薄いライト人間は応答にお伝えした頭に夢っていうのがどこに似合わないだと
思っていましたさっき今思っていますそれってさらに
ホール夢っていうのは人様から他にしないといけないんだって
ただし私はそれを試しに肯定してみたんですね
その肯定するっていう作業はきっと個々人に塞がれると思うんですけれども
そのここまでの話で何か好きっかからものが少しでもあった
ちょっと光を感じだよという人はその
そういった自分を肯定するって言うじゃねえよ今日から明日からぜひ進めてみてもらえ
たらなと思います
本当に最後の最後のスライドになりますけれども私みたいですね
シェイくるものが少しでも生きやすい社会になればと
こんな話で締めたいと思います
夢っていうものがですね
のかな人には向かないと思うんですね
なのでそこっていうふうに深く悩んでしまうのであれば
悩ん後やめるって言うことは大きな選択肢だと思います
そして2つめが夢を考えているよきてすごく自分に向かうんですね主戦がなぜその視点
をで分から覇者にです
なあべくその視点も身近な他者にすっ
これがすごく大変だと思います
そうすることで身近な誰かに貢献する自分っていうものて会えないですね
その自分に出会えたことによって新しいものばかりが走り出してみることができなかっ
た景色っていうものを楽しむことができるよう私は思っています
まあ方
3いいね
私みたいなんです
ぜひならないいただいて
家大学までも根に片手ます
そして卒業が半年と心は本当に自称フリカンみたい
知事も経て
本文あっち行ったりこっち行ったりっていうところでこんな話に倒れていたんですね
なのでぜひ今日の通っての中で
そういった寄り道を誰かはショートカットで期待
今もしも奴している部分があればその者やパパがちょっとでもラフになったりした
私はとても今日お話出来て嬉しかったなと思います
この写真で覚えたいと思います今日はありがとうございました